hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
India's dialogue the Phaedo Plato he has
Socrates discussing the immortality of
the soul among a lot of other topics
that are covered in other videos with
some of his interlocutors and simius and
K basis to Thebans they're the ones who
actually raised some of the most
pressing worries or objections about
whether the soul could in fact be
immortal which was important because
Socrates is about to die he's about to
drink hemlock and lose his life so you
know does he have any good reason for
the confidence that he says he has that
he's going to live another life one of
the possible objections to this that's
raised is a worry semiosis part and this
is a really interesting idea
so just by itself I think it'd be worth
you know having its own core concept
video but we also want to look at you
know Socrates response to it because
those arguments are also quite
interesting and then we want to think
about what would actually be proven by
Socrates arguments does it actually
prove that the soul is immortal or does
it just prove that this concept of the
soul is mistaken so what does simius is
worried
semia says maybe the soul is like a
musical instrument he talked a liar or a
harp but you could think of a guitar or
really anything you like think about it
the only thing about a piano right or
any any instrument that you like and the
instrument has strings those strings
make a kind of harmony maybe a chord we
would think of this in terms although
they didn't do a lot of portal stuff
back then it was more arpeggios and you
know playing the notes of the chord up
and down but think about a guitar you
strum the guitar or think about a banjo
you know you're strong the banjo banjo
is tuned to play the G chord even if you
don't have anything fretted guitar I
think is tuned to an E chord or
something like that okay so you've got
the instrument you've got its strings
you've got all these other things like
tuning pegs and all that but we have to
worry about that and you play them and
that makes a harmony now the harmony is
you would say secondary ontologically
the harmony comes after all the other
stuff it's a product or a function of
the other stuff so maybe the soul is
like that maybe the soul is actually a
harmony of the body and its elements or
its parts or however you want to think
about that now how was the body like a
guitar or a piano or any other sort of
stringed instrument it's not that much
like it but but the general idea is that
elements being put together in certain
ways and working in certain ways would
produce this effect of the soul and so
long as the elements are together in the
right way the soul remains but you you
you know think about the musical
instrument smash the guitar you even cut
the strings no more harmony destroy the
body you can't have a harmony of the
body's elements then right there they're
all scattered they go into different
places and by elements you know
Socrates you know plaintiff was thinking
of things like hot cold warm dry all
those sorts of things the physical
account but you can also think in terms
of other things
what would cutting the strings be like
well you know an awful lot of who we are
is dependent in our brains or on our
hormonal systems or on other things so
imagine you you radically damaged
something like that that would be sort
of like screwing up the strings and
therefore the effect would would be lost
so in this case the soul now you know
were there any people who actually
thought this at the time in ancient
Greece yeah you know arguably the
pythagorean's who are very interested in
music and numbers and stuff like that
and who tended to see things in terms of
numbers ratios all those sorts of things
they thought something kind of like this
if you read another platonic dialogue
the symposium you'll actually see this
character eric's amicus and he's putting
forth a a point of view that is more or
less compatible with this he's a he's a
medical doctor and he talks about the
body and it's harmonies and stuff like
that actually uses the word harmony at
that point what about today are there
are there people who see the soul or if
you don't like the word soul say human
personality is largely a function of the
body or you know even just perhaps just
the brain now there's plenty of people
who see things that way so it's a
plausible view you could also say if you
think you know in terms of science
fictiony kind of stuff think about these
science fiction stories in which a
person's mind is actually downloaded
into some sort of physical state
computer mainly through their memories
or something like that
you know all their experiences all
that's that's condensed there or you
know where you're trying to transport
people and you're like reconstituting
you know the whole being of the person
well then you know the personality or
the soul
be a function of the body wouldn't it
and if that's the case you know if we
don't we're in this computer kind of
thing
well you better watch the hard drive on
that or whatever it is that you're
storing that memory on because if it
gets damaged there goes the person so
this is kind of a plausible view isn't
it maybe more plausible than our own
times than it wasn't gonna play those
time so how can this be done well yeah
the arguments of Socrates maze
against this would at least go for you
know the sole being like eight a
stringed instrument and consider this
analogy and where the analogy would
break down so you have the harmony and
the harmony is something that comes from
the strings in proper alignment with
each other and that is itself dependent
on the instrument now consider the
relationship between the soul and the
body and its parts or elements or
whatever it is that we're going to
analogize to that is it the same sort of
relationship so Socrates points out
three main ways in which this isn't
going to work and the first way is
fairly simple third way is fairly simple
second way is they actually got a little
a little bit of complication or wrinkles
to it so let's let's look at the first
big issue well it comes you know right
from the fact that do you have a harmony
before you have this know you got to
have an instrument before you can have a
harmony and actually you know in a
certain sense you could say yeah but but
wait a second
how do you know how to play the
instrument or how do you how do you even
know how to
tune the instrument don't you have to
have a harmony didn't you know to align
that with before that's a plausible
objection but I don't think that would
actually strengthen the argument you
know for things for the soul being a
harmony in this case that would actually
make it a little bit a little bit
trickier so the what we say is the the
physical thing is ontologically prior
metaphysically prior it comes first as a
necessary condition for there to exist
the you know incorporeal harmony is that
the case with the body in the soul well
in the Platonic view that they're
working with no remember they're relying
on this doctrine of recollection they
already have taken for granted that the
soul exists before the body and its
elements and the soul itself might be
you know some sort of composite of
different things but it's going to be a
composite prior to the body so this
analogy doesn't really work for that
reason now that's you know that's a good
objection let's well we'll come to
actually I want to switch the order up
with this let's look at the third
objection then can i harmony be in a
state that's different from the elements
out of which its form or is it dependent
on those can the harmony resists the
elements can the harmony make the
strings sort of go differently than they
they would so to speak if we're gonna
extend this metaphor can the harmony
actually affect the instrument itself
and make the instrument do things that
it wouldn't ordinarily do and you know I
you know if I was gonna think about this
and think very broadly I would say well
yeah what about you know if you had a
guitar and it's an electric guitar and
you're too close to the amp and you
start to get some feedback and like
imagine a kind of feedback that would
ask
like you know undo the strings or
something like that
okay that's plausible nothing like that
available for play-doh so the answer is
No
a harmony can't resist or order around
or make you know something else do what
it doesn't want to do when it comes to
the instrument or the strings what about
the body and the soul well you don't
think about the things that the body
wants Plato talks about exercise
gymnastics think about what happens when
it will work out if you're working out
and you're actually doing it well you've
altered no pain no gain
why do you have to feel pain because
your soul is actually telling your body
I know you don't like this but you're
gonna do it anyway shut up and just keep
on doing reps okay well that's the soul
actually ordering the body around body
also has all sorts of desires
you know the body says hey I want to
drink I'm thirsty should you drink as
much as you want if you have if you've
been like marching around on a really
hot day no you should probably actually
drink fairly slowly otherwise you're
gonna screw your body up your body
doesn't carry bodies like drink drink
drink drink drink get as much as I can
and your soul says oh no no no no gotta
take it easy just a little bit at a time
okay these are just examples the soul
actually directs the body so the soul
can't be a harmony because harmonies
don't direct the things that their
harmonies up this is all very
interesting now I wanted to treat the
second argument separately because
there's a little bit more going on there
one of the things that Socrates asks
harmonies right harmony can be
more or less what do we mean think you
know about when something is slightly
out of tune it's not completely
harmonious now you you tune it and okay
now it's into right now it's more
harmonious it's more of a harmony as you
know they don't detune one of the
strings now it stops being as much of a
harmony and there's more discord yet I
think this Court is the opposite of
harmony I suppose another way that you
could say something becomes a harmony is
when you add more texture or layers to
it so we'll think of a chord 1st 3rd 5th
that's a basic chord structure for a
major chord add in the seventh and now
you've got you know a more complex chord
augment or diminish some of it you've
got a more complex chord that actually
that sometimes introduces kind of some
diss harmonies into it or dissonance
--is a B octave rather than the 7th and
another you know third and fifth now
you've got a more complex chord it's at
least got more stuff more harmony so
harmonies can be more or less what about
souls can a soul be more of a soul or
less of a soul you know that might be a
thought worth entertaining but at least
these interlocutors say nah that doesn't
make sense
it's either a soul or it's not a soul
it's either yes or no it's not a matter
of degrees like it is for harmony you
either got a soul or you don't get it so
either the soul exists or it doesn't
exist
one of the other picked up well that's a
problem isn't it because if the soul is
going to be a harmony
but a harmony has to admit of degrees
and the soul doesn't actually admit of
degrees that's going to be a problem and
now I was here now here's where it gets
really really really interesting so a
soul a soul can have things in it like
virtues or vices character traits that
you know are fairly resistant to change
that make the person act motivate them
have them perceive things in different
ways depending on who they are how they
you know how or how they are oriented by
virtues or vices so a greedy person as
opposed to a just person
Greta's a vice the greedy person is
going to look at things and see
opportunities to get over on people the
just person will see ah and not just not
opportunities but obligations to make
sure that everything stays within
certain limits doesn't transgress what's
due to another person with what they
deserve now here's where it gets really
interesting this is hard to follow a
little bit in the text for people who
are reading it for the first time these
virtues and vices
baby harmonies yes advice BIA kind of
discord yes that makes sense
and virtues and vices they admit more or
less somebody can be more courageous or
less courageous somebody can be more
lustful or less lustful we can pick all
sorts of things more intemperate less
intemperate choose Plato's terms you can
have more harmony less harmony more
opposite of harmony less opposite of
harmony within the soul and if that's
the case if you were going to say that
the soul itself is a harmony then you
would actually have a harmony within a
harmony as the soul if you had a virtue
in the soul imagine if you had like you
know five different versions you're just
temperate or just pious and wise all
right
you'd have five different harmonies
hopefully these these harmonies wouldn't
wouldn't jar with each other right the
soul would be incredibly complicated
that wouldn't it it would be an
incredibly complicated harmony that
incorporates other harmonies within it
does that really make sense to think of
it that way
well let's think about it the other way
the soul itself is a harmony the vices
are the opposite of harmony discourse
what would that mean is that within a
harmony you would have discordance --is
making it less of a harmony right and
we've already agreed that the soul is
either yes or no it's either on or off
you either have a solar you don't have a
soul it doesn't admit a degrees it's not
a more or less thing but if a vice which
is a discord could like make the soul
itself less of a harmony
then it wouldn't be this way it would be
a matter of degrees we've already said
that can't be the case so that that
can't work the soul can't be a harmony
but notice that doesn't mean that the
soul can't have harmonies and disk words
within it it just can't be a harmony see
the fundamental difference between
having on the one hand and being on the
other hand it's really quite interesting
to think about and Plato doesn't follow
this thought out I kind of wish that he
did but I mean that's something that we
can actually do on our own time is
follow out this notion of you know
virtues and vices as harmonies and
disharmony x' and how would they align
with each other with what vices they
actually like you know harmonize with
each other because they're discordant
what they actually be discordant to each
other that's an interesting question
that's not not being asked here and that
actually takes us beyond the realm of
the argument itself last thing that I
want to point out is all these arguments
show us that look this is not going to
work the soul is not going to be a
harmony and if that was standing in the
way of the soul being in mortal then we
have good reason to think that the soul
is immortal is that the only possible
objection that you would you would
possibly be able to make to the soul
being immortal knowit's that's not so
this doesn't this arguments or set of
arguments by itself does not actually
prove beyond a doubt that the soul is
immortal it just proves that if you want
to argue against that and you're going
to do it this way that's not going to
work so there's a big difference that's
where we'll leave long